Yeah. Come. I'm not. Next victim. Next
victim. I'm joking. What's your name?
Nice to meet you. What's your name?
Michael. I ask for your address. Ask for
your name. Michael. Michael. Michael.
Ask for name.
I'm joking.
Just one question. Yes. Because you
always throw in Arabic when you're
speaking. I listen to you online and
everything. I want to understand why do
you always
throw in Arabic? Firstly, I'm an Arabic
speaker. I'm Algerian. So my first
language is Arabic. Secondly, this how I
speak like you know just you know I use
Arabic terminologies like for example if
I'm in Algeria and I want to use some
terminologies which is
originally it's English terminology. I
will use English word then I translate
it. You understand? So what type of
Christian are you? No it's me asking you
a question but I want to understand
something. Yeah, I have a question. Why
was the Quran revealed in Arabic? I'm
not going to argue the point that you're
going to raise. I want to understand.
Okay. You cannot question according to
the Quran. No, the Quran first. You
cannot question Allah. Allah does
whatever he wishes. For as a Christian,
I will ask you why. You don't if you
want to answer, you can answer. Just to
show you to understand my point I can't
ask you today why God spoke to Jesus or
Jesus spoke in Aramaic why he speak in
English language of French no God does
whatever he wishes why God spoke to
Moses in Hebrew you know so God does
whatever he wishes but now some scholars
he has mentioned the wisdom behind
Arabic language Arabic language is so
rich the language is so rich for example
when you Arabic language
the sword you know sword he has 1,000
names has many names for so you can see
the the riches richness of the Arabic
language you mean likewise likewise the
language itself was never influenced by
the foreign languages you understand cuz
with the Arabs they were very isolated
and if you look back to the history that
time either you belong to the Roman
Empire or to the Persian Empire But the
the the the Arabs especially people of
Mecca, people of hij and other places
were not controlled by no empire. They
had their own tribes and so on. So
that's one of the the the the wisdom
because it's a clear language is a
language that is eloquent and is a rich
language. Allah knows best. That's one
of the wisdom but we don't know why
exactly. Allah doesn't ever wish. Okay.
According to the Quran, what does the
Quran say? The Quran Allah says, can you
think of any verse? There is a verse
here Allah
said in Arabic in order for you to
reflect upon it to understand it.
Likewise Allah said about the Arabic
language is
muban Arabic language is mu is clear
yes. Another reason
according to the Quran I don't know I
said to you that's the Quran look the
beautiful say that's it that's no that's
what I know according to me okay but it
shows you as well like for example in
the Quran we're talking about as a
Christian in the Quran tell us that
Jesus was not crucified that's someone
else if you pay attention the Quran
never tell us who is that person because
that information is not that important
Important information to know that God
saved Jesus from the humiliation that
the Romans and some Jewish people try to
afflict afflict Jesus with. You
understand this the is the most
important lesson that we need to take
from the story. Yes, there is some
scholars mention that was the person who
tried to betray Jesus the so on.
Likewise in the Quran for example, Allah
never taught us what was the type of the
stick that Moses used to become snake.
Some scholars said is that from that
tree these tree Allah never taught us
because that information is not
important information. Likewise Allah
told us in the Quran one of the the
people can take what Allah says in the
Quran Arabic but not in detail what
Quran emphasize on which is the most the
greatest important thing is to
understand what is your purpose in this
life and to understand the reality of
this life and the reality of the Satan
and the reality of the hereafter and the
reality of yourself that's the most
important thing and how to live this
life in the way that pleases your
creator.
I want to appeal to beautiful. Thank you
very much. Welcome very much. Great
answer. Can you appeal to the brothers
to find out if any of them know the
reason that's given by the Quran for
revealing the Quran in Arabic? I don't
need to do that because why? I have
respect.
No. No. Ask them. No, no. I'm saying if
anyone knows who is if anyone knows a
little bit more than you maybe just that
one
[Music]
thirsty please
huge animal yeah horses you know
seriously so does anyone know the reason
why the Quran was revealed in Arabic the
other people that just answer if you
have other if you know but not by
themselves scholars
I'm thinking one person might know. If
no one knows apart from what you just
said, that's fine. The one I know, they
know. Yeah. Okay. That's the one they
know. I read somewhere where it says
that it was
revealed to
the Arabs. It was revealed to the Arabs
so that they can understand
uh the Torah.
No. No. is wrong because yeah it's wrong
cuz why Torah we have clear historical
proof from the
prophetatam when he asked one of his
companions to learn Hebrew to understand
the Torah so yes Hebrew and Arabic and
Arabic and Aramaic and Syria called
languages and other languages for some
of them I can't remember the name
thesemitic languages mean they they are
ancient language yes there for example
which
mean which mean God in heaven.
Jesus spoke Aramaic. Yeah. Jesus never
spoke English. No French. I'd say maybe
Hebrew, Aramaic and Greek. Greek. No,
no, no. Aramic mainly. That was his
language. Historians would tell you
Aramaic because Aramaic was around him
spoke other languages. Aramaic. No, for
example, in Algeria, in Algeria, the
second language of Algeria, French, but
a lot of Algeria don't speak French. A
lot of them don't speak, they know some
words, Sabia, that's it. But they don't
know the French. You understand? And uh
Yeah. So, so what you keep asking
question, I want to ask question to you.
I was asking one specific question. No,
but I want to ask you a question which
is more important than any question
you've asked out of respect. Which is I
might not be able to answer. If you
don't know, no, you will be able because
the question I'm going to ask, you don't
have to have a qualification from Oxford
University or a Harvard University to
understand my question or from the
church. You don't have to be from
nowhere. You just utilize in your own
brain that God gave you is sufficient
for you to to recognize and to
differentiate between the truth and the
false. Okay. Is Jesus God? Jesus
according to the Bible? Yes. According
to you as a Christian? Yes. Okay. No.
No. Not according to me. According to
the
Bible that we follow as Christians. Yes.
For example, in John 1 say the beginning
with the word and the word with God and
the word was God. So that alone it says
something about the deity of Christ. Our
respect is not clear. No no to me it's
clear. Let's analyze it. In the
beginning where is it? With the word and
the word was with God. So there is in
the beginning was God and the word was
with God. So how many god we have
because the word going to become god. So
there's god and the word and the word
became god. How many god we have now?
Two god
okay in the beginning imag say in the
beginning was here in the park and jamal
was with and jam is how many we have?
Two. Yes. So it says in the Bible in the
beginning was the word
and the word was with God. So there's
the word and God. Yes. And the word
became God. So how many God?
Cuz the word that was with God became
God. So there's two gods. The word was
with God. Was with God. So that word was
with God. Was it God as well? The word.
Yes. So there's two gods. Now that
depends with say for example me I
believe in the trinity.
If if we go that way to me it makes
sense. If I don't believe in in trinity
how it makes sense that's how it makes
sense. Okay. Because we believe that the
word Jesus Yeah. is the word. Is he God?
I believe he's God. Is fully God. Fully
God. I would say half mix race. No. If
if you say half, you are half. Half.
Yeah. You are black as well, you know.
But I can see black in you. So you're
half. I can see black in you. But with
I'm African. Yes. I mean the hair the
hair is you are black.
Okay. Alhamdulillah. If I'm black, I'll
be proud of it. Alhamdulillah. My father
is color by the way. Yeah. Okay.
Alhamdulillah. Go on. But it's Algerian
like from different like countries.
Algerian. The best country in Africa.
100%. Thank you very much. I like that.
You already accepted already. It's too
late to change your mind.
Yeah. I was
saying asked me if Jesus was God.
I believe that Jesus is God. There was a
fully God. I believe Jesus is God
incarnate. Jesus is God that came down
to earth and took form of a human being.
Okay. Is that the father or another one?
No, I would say that God the son. The
son. So therefore there's two gods.
Jesus Christ, God the son. No problem.
There's two gods. God the father, God
the holy spirit according to and go the
son and go the son. No problem. That's
how I say no problem. Let me accept it.
But I'm saying accepting it. No accept.
That's how I hear accepted. The the so
Jesus God became flesh. Flesh and dwelt
among the father. It's not the father. I
would say it's not the father. Because
if you believe the father is a heretic,
if you believe the father himself became
flesh, he's a heretic. That is why I
mention trinity. That's why I had to
introduce trinity. I understand that
according to my belief, according to my
understanding of the trinity, God came
down and took human form. I understand.
But which God came down that came down?
The son. Godfather, God the father came
down in the form of No, no, The Bible
say that the Bible said the father loved
the world so much he sent his son that
he gave his only begotten son. Yes. But
he never said he himself became flesh.
That's a heretic. No. In the Bible
doesn't say that's all. So therefore
even the Bible is there anyone greater
than God? No. Is God the greatest all
the time? All the time. Yes. All the
time. If Jesus is God by default he
should be the greatest all the time.
What is this part of the godhead that we
are talking about? When I mention when I
mention
trinity, you see literally look Allah is
God. Watch this. Look at the Muslims.
Allah is God. Yes. Allah is great all
the time. That's it. Simple. If you tell
me Allah destroy this nation, that
nation, Allah still the greatest. But
the fact that you're struggling, you are
trying to I give you I show you. She'll
come to the side. Let's get a bit.
Sorry, it's a bit loud cuz I can't even
hear you and I'm right next to you.
Sorry, brother. That's it. Yeah. What
I'm saying? What I'm saying? I was
explaining. Listen to this. Yeah. I'm
saying Jesus is God. If Jesus is God by
default, God is the greatest all the
time. That's
it. So remember, what you going to say?
If Jesus god, yes. Yes. If Jesus the
great all the time. Yes. God. Okay. In
the Bible, Jesus said the father is
greater than I. So Jesus not the
greatest all the time. There's no trap.
I'm just showing you. It's not trap.
It's the truth.
So you now you're going to start now. I
see you intellect the truth or you going
to start fighting your own intellect.
According to the Bible,
according all the time. No, he is great
all the time. But Jesus said the father
is greater than I.
He accepted somebody was greater than
him. So he cannot be the grace all the
time. Someone greater than him. That I
don't know how to explain. No, not just
you. Jesus himself, if he believed he's
God, he never be able to explain it. But
Jesus never believed that right away.
Okay. He never believed. He never
believed he was God himself. I'll tell
you why. Yeah. Does God have a God?
Does God have a God? No. God have no
God. Come on. God has no God. God
simple. Yeah. You know in the Bible
Jesus said that I'm going to my father
and your father to my God and your God.
So if Jesus is God, how is he having
another God? You
know, but is that what it means that he
has another God? That's why he said I'm
going to my God and your God. Was he not
speaking from a position of Jesus of a
God that has come down in human form?
Was he not speaking from that position?
What do you mean by question? Because we
we believe that he came down. He took
human phone. Okay. In order to relate to
us. Okay. Was that what he was on a
mission to come and say understand us
human being? Yes. That's what the So the
father does not understand us. No, he
understands us. But you say in order for
him to understand us, he became human
being. So Jesus say he came on a mission
to save us. To save us or to kill
himself. But remember, God said he
doesn't change. Yeah, of course. I am
the Lord. I don't change. Why does he
turn into a human being? A human being.
Does it make sense? You know, in the
Quran, watch this. Yeah. You know, when
you look to the Quran, how Allah
describe himself. Please talk about I
will come to you. But just watch watch
just give you this. The
Quran say Allah is one and unique. Allah
saying Allah saying in the
Quran say oh Muhammad Allah is one
unique. Yeah. Allah is self-sufficient.
He's not in need of nothing.
Everything's in need of him. Yeah.
He beg not, neither was he begotten. No
one give a birth to him. Doesn't give
birth to no
one. And there's nothing like unto
Allah. Allah is the creator. You come to
Christianity, there is the father is
fully God. So we have one God. Yeah.
Then Jesus is fully God. We have another
God. But there not one God. There are
two God. No, they two one God. Okay.
Then you have another fully God. But
it's not one God. is still three gods.
It's one God. Watch this. Then you have
a God Jesus who self-sufficient. He was
in need of his mother to change his
nappy and to breastfeed him and to teach
him stuff. But God is the greatest. God
is the creator. Jesus is the big God is
the the greatest and the biggest.
However, Mary was bigger than God. She
put him inside her and she was able to
carry him. Okay? And
she doesn't make any sense. Oh, this
headache. I just Does it anyone
have or something? Well, five. I need
five. No one doesn't make any sense. I'm
sorry, but I'm Algerian. We joke too
much. Have respect. Out of respect. Have
respect. Yeah. Doesn't make any sense.
Polite. Look to the beauty and the the
simplicity and the clear of the
Quran. The teaching of the Quran. One
God. Perfect. Look, Jesus is God. God is
the greatest. But Jesus is someone
greater than him. Jesus is God. God know
everything. Yeah. God according to the
Bible Jesus said no one knows the day
and the hour. Not even the angels in the
heaven nor the son but only the father.
So
Jesus God and human both of them doesn't
know the the hour. This similar to the
Quran. Allah said in the
Quran they asked about day of judgment.
The meaning of the verse said no one
knows it except Allah. So Jesus judgment
when it will happen exactly except
Allah. So Jesus and the prophet Muhammad
said same thing. So prophet Jes like
prophet Muhammad they don't know
everything. So he cannot be God. Jesus
mighty messenger. No doubt about it.
True Messiah. No doubt about it. He was
born without a father. No doubt about
it. In the Quran we have many stories of
Jesus. Did you know that in the Quran
there's a chapter named after the mother
of Jesus? But there's no chapter named
after the mother of Muhammad.
So if the Quran was made by Muhammad,
why is going to name a chapter after
someone else mother but not his own
mother? And bear that in mind when he
was in Medina. Medina there was a lot of
Jewish people. If prophet
Muhammad wasallam was a false prophet,
he would have agreed with the Jewish
people in Medina who believed that Jesus
was not a messiah. But what prophet
Muhammad did, he disagreed with them. He
defended Jesus. He defended Mary. Even
though like from a material point of
view, if Prophet Muhammad was a liar, he
should have not defended Jesus.
He was a liar. He would have basically
become a people's pleaser. People claim
that if he was a liar, he should not
defended Jesus. Why in Medina? Because
to gain more followers. But to show you
prophet
Muhammad had no control over the Quran
is Allah the creator. I don't think
that's the greatest point to support
that. Yeah. Because the thing is someone
is a liar. Maybe was the greatest
strategist. No, no. If if someone to be
if someone claims to be a prophet. If
he's a liar, why he's lying? To gain
what? To get followers to gain
something. It can be anything. We have
to look into the situation. If someone
is a liar claiming something in this
life, he's not doing it to gain
something from God cuz he's lying
against God. So take God out picture cuz
we know for sure he's not do. So where
is the either? Either he's going to be
mentally and well. That's why I say
Unix. Possibility. Possibility.
Historically speaking, Prophet Muhammad
is the best man that walked upon the
face of the earth. We have many
non-Islamic historians testify that even
though we are not in need of it, but we
can bring them as an extra information
for you. Okay? He was not. Put them
aside. We are not in need of them by the
way. Just look at the teaching of
Prophet Muhammad. Look at his
legislation that he came with.
That shows you that this was so wise.
I'm not I want you to continue with
that. But I want to focus this
discussion on what does Prophet Muhammad
say about
salvation attaining salvation because
you're you're starting to talk about
what Prophet Muhammad teaches and his
characteristics impossible was a false
prophet. Yeah. So if you can can you
please direct the conversation to
salvation? Yes. Okay. So let me show you
now. Prophet Muhammad was a true prophet
and he was not a liar. Okay. when you
have to because Muhammad's teaching when
I talk about the medina point it's very
strong one because he was not mentally
well so he would the other option he's
saying it to gain followers to gain
suffer from this life and he was
expecting he wanted his own tribe
likewise the leaders of his Quraysh to
become to become a Muslim and the
leaders of Quraysh respected heavily uh
the the the rabbis in Medina so what he
could have did to get his to get
followers from his tribe Right? He could
have agreed with them with the Jewish
people to get the followers. But what he
did is agreed with them. He doesn't
care. They're going to follow him cuz
it's not about followers. It's about the
truth. Likewise, I want to show you. I'm
going to come back to salvation. He said
he said he said he was not mentally
wrong. What he meant if he was not
mentally wrong.
He was right the way he applied it. He
was
followed and say look what he says.
If some people if someone to prophet is
me or a liar okay okay so when you the
prophet Muhammad I want to mention
something very important then I'm going
to come back let's start with salvation
yeah please I will come back I want to
come back salvation but when you analyze
the story of Mary in the Quran and the
story of Mary in the Bible the Quranic
story is more intellectual more logical
I'll tell you why about intellect and
logic
Because God gave us this tool which is
intellect, sound intellect and natural
inclination to utilize them to determine
the truth and the falsehood. For
example, like God, he's not going to
give me sound reasoning call universal
tools. Every human being have it. If
every human being have it, we must got
it from what? From God. If every human
being have a soul, God gave it to us.
You understand? You cannot always be
Mary. Do you believe Mary she had a son
called Jesus without a father? Yeah.
Like I believe with logic we cannot we
cannot work. No we can we can because if
God the greatest create Adam without a
man or woman then he create Eve from a
man not a woman is able to create man
from a woman. Logical rational argument.
So so so it means he can do certain
things. Yes. That are seemingly
illogical. No because he is God. No. No,
how is illogical? If we accept which one
is greater in creation, this universe or
human being? The universe. Universe. So
if Allah is able to create this universe
is logical, rational is able to create a
human being from no mother, no one. It's
a logical rational. Yeah. Yeah.
Alhamdulillah. And this argument I just
used, guess where is it? It's in the
Quran. Yeah. It's a Quranic argument.
That's why the Quran sal for go
salvation. Don't try to jump. Okay.
We're talking about the Mary story. When
you look to Mary, remember she was a
Jewish salvation is very important to
summarize the Quran is simple. Salvation
salvation first, you get it by the mercy
of God. Mercy. Yeah. Not your actions
because you regardless how much actions
you do, you will never be able to repay
back Allah for his blessings. You
understand? Even prophet Muhammad
wasallam said, he said, "Everyone means
those who deserve it will enter to
paradise by the grace of God." They say,
"Oh Muhammad, oh messenger of Allah,
even you," he say, "Even me." So in
Islam, the first thing is the grace and
the mercy of Allah. Of course, God is
the most just. Likewise, your belief and
your actions. You understand? You know
what I'm saying? So we we believe that
we have to be spotless to enter heaven
as
Christians. But we cannot achieve that
by ourselves, by our works or by uh just
praying to God. We cannot achieve that
as human beings. So that's where we need
Christ to make sure that we are pure to
enter heaven. So you believe that that's
our belief. But I'm going to show you
your belief. It goes angers the old
testament. I'm going to show you. But
let me before I move on to that. No,
what I'm talking about is a new
covenant. We believe in what the new
covenant. That's what Jesus came for.
But Jesus never believed that. I will
show you from the the New Testament as
well. No, but did you hear what I said
about salvation? I understand that you
believe you were explaining. I explained
my position as a Christian. Christ came
down on a mission to die for our
sins. So we can never be clean enough to
earn heaven. We cannot even if we do all
the good
works still that is as filthy as filthy
rugs in front of God. That's what we
believe. So in order for us it's a
paradise for us to be clean. Yeah.
So
Jesus
Christ. So the blood of Christ is what
makes everything clean. Okay. No, not
because we are good. Not because we are
perfect. I understand your point. But
Jesus made it better. I'm going to
discuss it after through the story of
Mary. Yes. So I'm I'm going to go to the
end just two seconds. Okay. Go ahead. So
we believe that Jesus was crucified on
the cross as an ultimate sacrifice.
There's no no more sacrifices to be made
to to be made for the cleansing of the
sins. Okay. Yeah. Jesus was the ultimate
sacrifice. So that's what we believe and
that's how we attain salvation. How do
we attain this salvation? By just
accepting Jesus into our heart and we
say I honor what you did on the cross
and I just live my life according to
what he uh Jesus taught. what Jesus
taught. Okay. So that's how we attain. I
I was discussing according to Christian.
Okay. Just let me show you what you
believe. When a young boy came to Jesus,
I was going to mention the story of
Jesus Mary in the Qur and the Bible. I
mention after. But to deal with your
point, a young boy came to Jesus in the
Bible. He said, "Oh, a good master. What
should I do to inherit the kingdom of
heaven?" Yeah. So this young boy is
asking Jesus, "How is going to do you
mind continuing with that verse?" I'm
going to continue. I'm going to finish
all of it. Okay. So, the young boy is
asking the young boy is asking Jesus how
to enter the kingdom of heaven. Jesus
never told him believe I'm going to die
for your sins and you'll be saved. What
Jesus said? What he said? He said, "Keep
the commandments of God, which mean the
Torah, the Mosaic law." And what is the
Mosaic law teach you? The Mosaic, the
Mosaic law and the the Torah law teaches
you that if you commit the sins and you
repent to God and you turn away from it,
God will forgive you and you will enter
paradise. Very similar to the Quran.
Subhan Allah. So now now Jesus is
directing the young boy to follow the
Mosaic law. The young boy said, "I have
been doing it since I was young." I was
young. Yes. Jesus said to him, "But you
are lacking one thing." He said, "What
is it?" He said, "Give your wealth away
then follow me." You understand? So my
point here is there's no one more
clearer, more eloquent, more sincere
than the prophets and messengers
including Jesus. There's no one speak
clear and precise and give good advice
like Jesus, Moses, Muhammad, all of the
prophets of God. Okay? So if Jesus that
was the best time for Jesus to tell the
young boy believe I'm going to die for
your sins and you'll be saved. But I
never said that. He said keep the
commandments of God and the the law of
God rais it. There's too many law in the
Torah. Stay away from this stay away
from that also to follow many things.
Likewise so Jesus here which is very
there's another passage which is in
Ezekiel. Ezekiel God said if you commit
a sin your father should not should not
be responsible for your own sin and your
father sin you should not be responsible
same thing in the
Quran no one should be responsible for
no one's sins and if you do good deed if
you do a sin then you turn away against
it and you do right action God will
forgive you why why did you mention that
verse Ezekiel I'm following yeah I'm
showing you according to the prophet in
the Old Testament even to some passes
passages in the Bible. It shows you
clearly is about mercy of God of course
but also about belief and actions. None
of them came with this out of respect is
a pagan teaching that was influenced by
the pagan Romans that Paul entered it
and some of the Greek uh uh writers
Matthew influenced by the Roman pagan
teaching start adding this lie that
Jesus died for your sins. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. Because also you have to
understand many look just utilize our
intellect. Let us see which one go and
guess the prophet Abraham and Moses and
and Isaac and Abra and Jacob and all the
prophets of the Old
Testament. All the prophets in the Old
Testament all the prophets in the Old
Testament came which teaching came with
the
teaching you'll be responsible for your
sins.
Do righteous action you enter paradise.
No one is going to die for your sins.
Until for the sake of argument, who
came? Jesus. Jesus said for the sake of
argument. He never said that. I'm going
to die for your sins. Then who came
after? Prophet Muhammad said you'll be
responsible for your sins. If
if you do right action, so logically
speaking, if you do righteous actions,
what? If you the mercy of God, believe
in God, do right action, you go
paradise. We believe that. We cannot
reach that stage where clean
enough coming
back this guy is brother he's very
respectful guy please you know yeah I
know you know even stop stop so anyway
what I'm
saying I put some go I put some olive
oil
Sorry. It's loud, man. Okay. We're going
to end up with a joke. I
know. Let's start talking about
something else. We start hallucinating.
Be with you, please.
Can I take a picture?
You get away.
Yeah. We don't want to get
too. You should be charging, brother. I
just got the brother's cameras. You have
to get a cut some of the cameras. Okay.
Helping help the other comes
[Music]
because where were So we were here we
were of death
three
times move cuz there's a can you bring
this one here you know these brothers I
don't know why they leave their cameras
cuz they can't they make us do their job
bring the camera as well there's a
camera they bring
it can you bring that camera
please bring it here sorry you know it's
a trust they
left anyway what I was going to say So
what I'm saying logically, rationally
speaking, if you look to the prophet
that is out of order, if you want to use
the word or the one who opposes all the
prophets is Jesus. Prophet Muhammad goes
in line, his teaching goes in line with
Moses. Uh generally speaking, Moses,
Jeremiah, Daniel, Abraham, all of them
came. Isaac, all of them came. You'll be
responsible for your sins. I'm not sure
if you know about the trinity, it says
about anyone that is hanged on the on a
cross or a tree is cursed. You know
that. So Paul who tried to propagate
Christ that's why Christ had to be
crucified. No that's why Paul when he
noticed this this teaching about Jesus
died on the cross and it has to he he he
needed to justify it cuz he noticed that
the Old Testament curse. So he said
Jesus became cursed because of our sins.
Let me ask you what is different between
then? What is Jesus never became cursed?
Jesus is holy man. We believe all the
time. What then? What is the difference
between Jesus and a
Satan? Lucifer was an angel man. Who was
angel according to your belief? He was a
righteous man because the Bible was a
righteous man like the Quran. He was a
righteous man. Then he became cursed.
Jesus he was a righteous man. He became
cursed. According the Bible, Jesus and
are saints. according to Quran. No, I
think they
um you have a different understanding of
that verse. My understanding as a
Christian is he took upon our curse.
So he became cursed because our sins.
Yeah. Because he took Yes. the curse
that was supposed to be on us. So So
Jesus, was he holy or cursed? Jesus was
holy. But he said he become cursed.
Yeah. Because he took our curse. So he
become cursed. He was cursed. Yes. So
he's not holy. You can't be holy and
cursed. Holy someone's clear from curse.
Curse is when you go when God take you
out of his mercy. I was explaining that
verse. It doesn't mean that he became a
curse and a permanent curse. No, that's
why he said he became he actually took
our curse. He became cursed. Okay. He he
never took our curse and he put it in
the water. He took it upon himself. He
took the curse. He took the curse and he
went on the cross. Let me give example.
Okay. So then he the curse. You
understand what I'm saying? Then the
curse was removed. Yes. But there was a
time when he was cursed. Yes. So it was
not holy that time. He was cursed.
You can say that. That would be if
that's what you're saying. It's a lie.
That's what you're saying. I respect I
believe. I'm just using our rationality.
That's what it gives birth to. No,
that's what it gives a birth to. Like
brother GMA mentioned. We're not going
to hide away from the fact that he took
upon the curse. No. No. What I'm I want
to do I want to step when I say step up
meaning you should utilize your
intellect as you're a smart person. You
don't have problem. Listen carefully.
Let me finish my point out of respect.
Utilize your brain and think you know
what how someone like Jesus we can't
accuse him that he became cursed and
Satan became cursed. Wait prophesy is
going to come down. Let me hear you
crucified to take away the sins of the
world. No no but I want you to hear
that. I understand that you believe but
but all of that belief is what Jesus
believe. That is Paul wanted to believe
in this. No, if you attack Paul then we
have no basis. That's what I'm saying.
That's you you're a pol follow follower
not Jesus. No, no, but that's you saying
that's what you said. If you if you
attack Paul, you have no basis. You have
nothing to stand on. No, I'm saying we
can't even talk about any about my
religion. You don't want to accept the
things that Paul says. Where are you
going to stop? Okay. If I show
you if I show you there was a problem
between Paul and James Jesus half
brother. Yeah. have a problem with.
So I'm not the first person to have a
problem with Paul. I'm showing you even
Jesus half brother who was a follower of
Jesus had a problem with Paul and Paul
did lie. Is it not true in the Bible? I
want to focus on salvation. Okay between
the brothers of Jesus and all the see
but shows you there's a problem with the
gospels. That's what I'm showing you.
Where is the problem when it comes to
salvation salvation that's what I'm
saying in Islam talk about that's what
I'm saying the salvation that is by Paul
is a wrong salvation the salvation that
is in Islam it goes in line with Jesus
teaching that's what I'm trying to
establish I'm showing you why you cannot
trust Paul there's many problems with
Paul you understand based upon that
verse where Paul said why God is going
to judge me the law listen to this yeah
Paul said why God is going to judge me
If my lies glorify God
more. So he said what is the problem if
if my lies helps me to glorify God. Same
one said Paul said if I go to the Jewish
people I'll pretend to be a person with
a law with a Torah and if I go someone
without a law I pretend to be someone
without a law in what is it? Hypocrites
to be hypocrites. So sal to show you the
salvation of the old testament and the
Quranic one generally speaking is the
same that about the grace of god
believing believe in god correctly doing
righteous actions yes I do agree with
you no acting the work of the cross
that's where you have yeah yeah yeah and
a poor speech poor speech is a lie I
believe he's a lie because like I said
to you I'm sure you Paul had a problem
with the followers of Jesus is in the
Bible when he had a problem with Jesus
half brother James because Paul said
it's not about following the law it's
about what it's about the faith you
don't you're not circumcising anymore
because Paul said it's not about the
circumcision it's about circumcision of
the heart yes okay and I want to show
you something in the old testament said
God will bless those who bless Abraham
Muslims when we pray what we say
Ali Muhammad. Oh Allah bless Abraham and
the family of Abraham. So the Muslim
always bless Abraham and the Bible God
said I will bless those who bless
Abraham. So I want to just finish with
your story and I thank you for it very
much for being respectful and forgive me
if I said anything rude to you you know
because Paul I'm just showing you you
cannot trust someone not because of me
because even there many early followers
of Jesus did not trust Paul but I want
to conclude with this then I can tell
you you know the story there might be
evidence to the contrary of what he just
said that even the early believers
didn't trust Paul the father is the
father of the faith so I'm sure there's
a possib
ability that how can he be the father
would disagree disagree with no there is
but but what I'm saying there there look
what you have to understand what's your
name I never c your name again you said
Michael Michael yeah Michael yeah sorry
forgive you Michael what I was going to
say Michael everyone can have
justification even the rapist and the
murder will just justify what he's doing
but doesn't mean because you can justify
it it's valid and it's correct what I'm
showing you that I'm not showing you
taking that as principle then we can
apply to everything that you say
everything that you justify. That's what
we're doing here. We're analyzing.
That's what we're doing. So that one is
is a mute point because apply to you
when you're talking about prophet
justification. We're not going to have a
discussion. No, we can cuz there's
there's justification. For example, if
someone said to me why you murdered so
and so I say tried to rape my sister,
there's a valid justification. But if
someone ask you why you murder so and
so, you say I don't like his hairstyle.
That's that's so so so I'm saying yeah
we look at the justification if it's
married or not but I just want to finish
with this story the story Mary was a
Jewish woman according to Judea if she
commits adultery she'll be stoned to
death so according to the Bible when God
gave a child to Mary when she got
pregnant
the Holy Spirit came to Joseph Carpenter
tell him to marry her okay but everyone
knows He was he's not his father
biological father. So that doesn't make
any sense. So how who was his biological
father? The question still stands. Where
did you get your son from? But also the
Quranic story. Why are you asking for
your biological? I'll tell No, no. I'm
I'm showing you the story is for her to
be protected against the rabbis to
establish the stoning adultery to stone
her is not real logical rational
justification because they knew that
he's not he's not his father I'll give
you example imagine your daughter came
to you sorry and she said to you Michael
my dad I'm pregnant are you married she
says no I'm not married you have
boyfriend no gave it to me would you
believe her No, if you go are you
mocking me? But if she says to you, I'll
show you a proof that God gave me this
child. The child is in the cradle and
the child start speaking to you and
start defending her. Would you believe
her now?
Of course, there's a miracle. How child
speak in the cradle? Me, I believe in
miracles anyway. My first my first
answer was just to accommodate to let
you speak. I believe in miracles. No,
what I'm saying about this miracle. Put
aside No, no, put aside you believe in a
miracle or not. Anyone here if I see a
child speaking cleanly all of us witness
it defending his mother we will take it
yes because you see that's not a given
because maybe I'll start questioning my
sanity. No that that's that's see a tree
when they high no I understand that but
when is it clear if you don't believe in
miracles if I believe in miracles I
won't have problems. No, no, no. What
I'm saying Jesus why Jesus show miracle
to some people to believe in him
that he was from God. Sometimes he was
just doing it because there there was
need say for example okay why Moses gave
miracle to Pharaoh why Moses demonstrate
the power of God that's to show Yahweh
Jesus never called God Yahweh in the New
Testament
talking about you talking about Moses
yeah but but he's not just called Yahweh
in the Old Testament. He doesn't have a
name. For example, what they call it.
I am who I am in Hebrew language. So I'm
saying don't let us focus on name. No no
no just some words. Don't speak Hebrew.
So the point here is I'm showing you the
the story of Mary in the Quran is more
logical rational because when when Allah
me the Quran the chapter of
Mary wrote
in oh the sister of Arun your father was
not evil man your mother was not a
fornicator bro I'm start smelling this
cannabis thing I'm going to start
speaking about some crazy
things talking about you know what I'm
saying is that the hash is let's go
let's go what are you saying no I'm
enjoying it to be
honest let's go or stay no no you're
enjoying it as well
I'm joking so what I'm saying with the
Quranic teach the story of Mary is
logical, rational. He says, "So Mary's,"
she said, "She point at
him, she point at him." You know what
they
said? How can we speak to a child in the
cradle?
So the first thing he said, so he's
having discussion with them. I'm the
servant of Allah to to to refute the
lies that he's the son of God or God.
I'm I'm going to let you finish
explaining everything that you just
everything that just happened there. I
have one question. Why did you revert
back to that was Arabic Arabic? Yeah. So
why did you have to That's a good
question. I want to understand. That's a
good question to make sure to keep the
Quran in its original way. That's why we
never lost the Quran because we keep
reciting it the way it was revealed. If
we start reciting in different languages
without recite the Arabic, it could be
many people forget it. Spiritual reason
for reasoning it. Yeah. I mean like the
Quran look the Quran was written Arabic.
The Quran English even the Quran is not
literally the Quran is the translation
of the meaning of the Quran. But the
English one is not the Quran. It's a
translation just a translation of the
meaning of the Quran because the Quran
God spoke with which is is a miracle.
You understand? So and
how so so they said he I'm servant Allah
refuting the lies son of god or god then
he said he defend his mother as well.
You see that's why they couldn't
establish the mosaic law which is
stinging the ad tree. Yeah. So we're
looking at and this you know I mentioned
this story this happened to me in acting
in the barber shop. I was sitting down
and there was this some Jamaican guys
having debates with one African
Christian guy and they were telling him
this doesn't make any sense how she got
pregnant we go I will he the Jamaican
guy he said I will kill my daughter you
know he says according to Mosaic law
he's not say I would do it he said
according to Mosaic law I will kill her
because why she commit adultery when I
told them about the story of the Quran
they were not Muslims they were not
Christians they were just they just
believe in God they said the story of
the Quran is more rational
logical which is subhan Allah that's why
I advise you to become Muslim to believe
in true teaching of Jesus we haven't
even started on the issue of salvation
so I told you clear I believe that I'm
saved I believe that I can be according
to I cannot be clean enough to earn my
way to salvation so therefore I need
Christ okay what about before Christ I I
wasn't alive before Christ I'm talking
about Now in my life understand you're
saying come to Christ. Okay. Are you
saying so on the past forget the past. I
understand what you're saying you're
saying that I can apply. Yeah. But what
I'm saying you are saying that in order
for us to enter paradise now and the
kingdom of heaven we're not clean enough
to enter it except by accepting God
sorry Jesus. Jesus died for our sins. So
his blood. I understand it very well.
But I'm saying it's not according to
Jesus. It's not according to the Old
Testament. is according to the the the
writers and the authors of the New
Testament who attributes the lies to
Jesus. When I just showed you I sorry I
give you an example when Jesus was asked
clearly about the salvation which is
entering the kingdom of heaven. He never
said to the young boy believe I'm going
to die for your sins. Likewise that you
quoted me God is the most just. Correct.
No, no. Are you referring to that verse
that you just the whole passage? Yeah.
Is God's is God the most just? He's the
most just. So are you telling me all
that time before Jesus, those people
were clean enough to enter paradise,
they were human beings like you and I.
But God clearly said to them, if you
turn away from your if you turn away
from your from your evil sins and you
repent and you do good deeds, you enter
paradise. And it's exactly what Allahh
said in the Quran. But yet Allah
mentioned that in the Quran and I don't
know if you know about the Bible Old
Testament if you commit a sin God will
double
it is an old testament in the Quran what
is it if you commit a good deed Allah
will double it so who is more loving
more merciful here is a point what I had
to mention as an extra cuz the
Christians drive us crazy God loving is
more more than Allah we believe in the
same God generous een but you attribute
some stuff so what I'm saying what you
believe about salvation is No problem.
No problem. Sorry for shouting
sometimes. I'm Algerian. Always. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm Algerian. Yeah. I listen to
you. Sorry, Michael. Many times I I try
to promise
myself speak normal. Don't shout. It's
normal. But I can't. I'm African. I'm
Africa. I'm black like you.
Where you from? Where you from? What
country? Africa. Africa is all Africa.
Now they can be all Africa. Algeria.
Africa. Africa. But where in Africa?
Africa.
From Do you mind if I ask him a
question? You can ask.
We believe already that
Jes are going to be Are you going to be
available to discuss it? Not just in and
out. I just want to ask that if you
believe that Jesus already died for for
your sin, right? So you can do Yeah.
your sin. So you can do whatever you
want to do. No. No, no, it it doesn't
work like that.
So, if you if you believe that Jesus
Christ died for your sins as a
Christian, can I take a picture?
Brother, brother, I want to take a
picture.
Yeah. Yeah. So, give me two second. I
want to take a picture with brother.
I've been talking about salvation,
right? So, if if you if you believe that
Jesus died for your sins, you have to
show respect as well, isn't it?
So you're living your life to what you
think is right by knowledge for you for
the work that you did on the cross which
is taking away all
so this is not a passport to say you
know what now you can just
you ask me a question I will explain
I'll stop you than 2 minutes we believe
that when you accept Christ as your
savior Yeah, you are not going to be the
same. You become a new creation.
And now you don't leave. If you were a
drug dealer before, you're no longer
What was the question? You're no longer
a drug dealer. The same question that
you
now
already go somewhere. That mean no.
No, but I explained to you and you heard
what I said. What did you say? So I said
it's not a free pass to say now you can
live your life anyhow. You actually have
to show that you respect Jesus and the
work that he did on the cross. So it's
conditional. No, no, no. I'm still
explaining. I'll get to the end. All
right. Cool. If you have a problem with
it, you can always come back. Yeah.
So you have to show respect for the work
that he did on the cross. That's one
thing. Two, the Bible itself is it say
just because you have received Christ
now you are a new creation. All the old
things have passed away now you have
become new. So your heart has to be
renewed and you have to walk like
someone who has been transformed. That's
our belief as Christians. So there's no
passport that says you know what now
you're saved. Go and do whatever your
sins will be forgiven. Doesn't work like
that. But no, did you hear what I said?
What's your what's not clear?
Bible. Not just respect. I said it's a
requirement that you actually have to
walk like someone who's been
transformed, someone who has received
Christ become a new creation. It's
conditional then. It's conditional upon
the Christians. When a
Christian when you ask Christians they
never tell you it's conditional for for
your sins to be forgiven that you have
to follow. No there's no condition on
that. Why you say condition? He said you
have to follow this and that. No no he
is asking particularly on the about
dying for your sins. No no no about
having a free pass to do that. No that
is not allowed and and it's not expected
of you. But that's nothing to do with
salvation though. To do salvation how I
tell you you receive Christ you enter
heaven. Okay. You do your best. So I
receive. So now if if someone believes
that Jesus died for his sins. Okay. So
meaning that person sins all of it is
been removed from him. Correct. Yes.
Yeah. So so wait. Yeah. Past and future
sins. Okay. So and now he can do
whatever he wishes then cuz he paid off.
This is the paid
off to be honest for him to do more sins
for for to for Jesus blood not go to
waste no it's like me paying money for
your food and you don't buy no food
waste my money if that's how you process
it back logical
rational logical rational to be honest
no you are more logical if you think
you're more logical than the structure
that that already exist I only explain
the human being you should utilize our
I explained the position of a Christian.
You are not expected to go and do I'm
just showing ourselves. What is that?
You are not expected to do the
old joke.
Yeah, forgot my answer to your question.
That's what I'm saying. It doesn't make
any sense. I respect why I'm saying you
are say sorry. So if someone believed in
Jesus except Jesus however continue to
do sins he he's not will not enter
paradise because he's doing still doing
sins for him for Jesus sacrifice
according to belief to be accepted this
person must stop doing sins
so you were not listening to what I say
no I listen to you he wasn't I listen to
you he understood it understood it you
don't You know how after he dies from
all the sins. Yeah. And you got to work
on respect as you say. You don't have a
free passport to see.
You do the minimum after that.
You Yes. You enter heaven not because
you you managed to get to that level
where you're spotless. No, no. The work
of the cross is what what cleans your
your sins. Without that you cannot
enter. Just to make it clear. He died
from the scene. But you're saying that
you got to work on respect
respect. You're showing appreciation for
what happened. Don't want to leave.
That's what I'm saying. So if you show
if you appreciate what Jesus did to him,
then I appreciate what he did to me. But
I want to enjoy my life
by doing fornication.
No. No. You are not expected to do that
to do that. That's what I say. I'm
saying disrespecting. That's why I'm
saying it's conditional. You have to
show respect by stopping doing sins. The
only condition That's what I'm saying.
It's conditional. The only condition,
yes, is you have to accept Christ into
your heart. You've become a new
creation. That's how you and you have to
do it through actions. You are through
actions. It's not by works. Okay. If
it's not by works, can I continue those
sins and enter paradise? That's why I
say you are not expected to do that. So
why are you doing it? No, but I'm human
being. That is the default nature of
default nature. So you're not safe. So
you expect me to be perfect. But we know
many Christians. I'm not expecting you
to be perfect.
That's what I'm saying. But you just
said in order for you to enter paradise,
you have to be spotless only by the
blood of Christ. That's what I'm saying.
We believe that's because of your works.
That's what I'm saying. I can never say
I don't believe. If you continue doing
sins if you continue, this person
continued doing sins. Okay. Would he
enter paradise?
Are you saved? Did you receive Christ?
Yeah, he believed Jesus. He believed in
Jesus. I believe that you you enter
heaven. Yeah. Even if you're doing
crimes and sins and everything. Yeah.
No, you have to walk like someone don't
matter about work. He said it matters
about work. You see it matters about
work. You have the caveat respect
Michael.
Michael what you just said what he just
said out of respect. He goes and gets
Jesus teaching. Jesus in the Bible said
when the young boy came to him he said
oh good master what should I do to
inhand the kingdom of heaven.
Jesus. Never said to the young boy,
"Believe, I'm going to die for your
sins." He said, "Keep the commandments
of God." He was referring to the Mosaic
law. Mean follow the Mosaic law. And the
Mosaic law means to do good deeds, to do
a work. So Jesus clearly is telling the
young boy to be saved and to enter the
kingdom of heaven, you have to do good
works. The young boy said to him, works
alone. That's what Christ comes in. No,
but you agree with us. We agree with you
that you need mercy of God. But you come
with you don't need work. You need the
the blood of Jesus. But according to
Jesus, Jesus never said that. Jesus said
to the young boy, keep the commandment
of God. The young boy said to him, said
to him, I've been doing it since I was
young. Jesus said to him, you are
lacking one thing. He said, what is it?
He said, give your wealth away and
follow me. You understand? So this the
salvation of
Jesus is not sorry. He's following the
Paul. That's why he's doing it. That's
why Christians now they are a Paul
followers, not Jesus followers. That's
why if you want to believe in Jesus
correctly, become a Muslim.
How do you follow Jesus as a Muslim? As
a Muslim, I believe in Jesus. For
example, I follow him that when he
accepted when he said to the people, he
was not God or a son of God. I follow
that statement and I say yes. Where did
he say that? In the Quran. In the Quran.
No, as a Muslim. I know in the Bible.
I'm a Muslim. I follow Quran. Not from
the Bible cuz your question said as a
Muslim you tell me as normal human
being. Okay. And in the in the Bible to
show you that Jesus when someone call
him or a good master he say why you
calling me good no one is good only God
alone. So Jesus doesn't want people to
call him good let alone to call him God.
You know in the Quran he gives you a
powerful argument. Allah said about Jes
and his mother both of them used to eat
food. That's not God nature. God is
self-sufficient. If God is in need of
food, he cannot be the same God who is
self-sufficient. That is not God's
nature to have God to have food.
Likewise to have God as I showed you Jes
in the Bible, Jesus said, "I'm going to
my God and your God." That doesn't make
any sense. What's your understanding of
the mission of Christ coming down to
earth? The mission according to Islamic
teaching why Jesus the true Messiah, the
mighty man, the mighty messenger came to
to the earth to teach people how to
worship the creator and to correct some
lies of the Jewish people against God
and against the prophets of God. That
was his main teaching. All the prophets
including prophet Muhammad and
Mosesat wasallam all of them came to
teach us in detail what is our purpose
in this life and to show us how to gain
God's pleasure and how to stay away from
the pleasure of
Satan you know Islamic teaching our
ultimate goal is
God following God like I show you many
things you know you know let me ask you
a question Yeah.
You from Africa? Like I'm from Africa.
Yeah. Yes. There is from Haiti. Haiti?
Yeah. Okay. You from Africa? No. No.
Africa. But originally you from You're
from Haiti. Let's move. You You don't
like to joke? I'm joking. Where you
from? Africa. Where? Zimbabwe. Zimbabwe.
Algeria is the best. Algeria with the
best country in the world. Second best.
No, no, no. You already said yes. Agreed
with me.
What would we say to you? I know about I
know about uh what do they call it uh
yes they were Christians way before but
majority of African countries European
came to our countries and force
Christianity on us not just tell us
become a Christian no literally like I
told you I'm not sure if I told you I
told someone else I told you my father
was put in prison in France when the
French cuz he was fighting against the
French they put him in prison for 10
years and they enslaved him in prison
and And they tried to force to become a
Christian and alhamdulillah stood firm
against it. So what I'm saying to you
the which people are the
French occupied Algeria. Yeah. Occupia
from the year 18 1832 to 1962 for 132
years. Why I'm telling you why I'm
saying this to show you that about
uh the point of dimension about Africa.
Yes. The same people that brought
Christianity to us, they have left it.
Britain is just Christian with name.
They left Christianity. Majority of
majority of people are not majority. A
lot of Christians having night doing a
nightclub or going nightclub on Saturday
night. Sunday they hang over. They can't
go to church. They're too drunk to go to
church and they don't even they go to
church they give them more wine. What
kind of teaching is this? Anyway, anyway
where you got the information? No. I'll
tell you there is information. There is
a data listen let me give you a data
there is a data that comes out in
Britain every 10 years there is a data
in Britain in Algeria in Britain after
10 years they find that Islamist and
Muslims are increasing Christianity is
declining why because a lot of bothered
with the politics the western
world salvation become Muslim believe in
God follow God's teachings you might be
wrong no I'm showing you data The data s
is data. Let me show you. We can do can
data. I'll show you how. I'll show you
how my we can do experimentation. Get
your own camera. I got my own camera. We
go Friday to the mosques and we go sign
it to churches. Churches are turning
into swimming pools. Go read the
newspaper. I've read it. They say
churches are we have bought five
churches. We turn them to the masjid.
That's what I like about the western
world now. You know, they don't care
about Christianity anymore. They will
sell you church.
Maybe it's because they've secured 20
cinemas. Why 20 cinemas? Oh, because
they are empty. No one is there.
Like, look how many young Muslims here.
There's no Christians here. We're taking
over, man. I'm not the bloody Muslims
are taking over. No, we're not taking
over. We're joking. You know, we
appreciate that you welcome us here. You
know, we have to be, you know, some
Muslim they go to extreme. We are here
like the extremist. No, as a Muslim, I
appreciate. No, no, I'm joking. You know
me I'm actually a joke. I told you we
talk to which you are taking over. No
we're not taking over by sword or
nothing but Islam is spreading in
Britain. Many British women are
accepting Islam. Even though there is a
huge propaganda against Islam that Islam
oppress women but in Britain majority of
reverts are women. Subhan Allah. We're
not using no spoon no for no weapon to
force them to become Muslim. They they
becoming Muslim by their own choice. And
Allah mentioned that in the Quran, one
years ago, I'm going to tell you what I
promised them. I promised them that
Allah Jenna paradise also we promised
them that we take care of them. We look
after them. Alhamdulillah, we we run
after the bus. Not my wife run after the
bus. As long as you're not getting the
weak, you know. Yeah. No, no.
Alhamdulillah. Look. Alhamdulillah. They
know that the true salvation cuz they
see that true meaning
of freedom is in Islam. They try to say
islam enslave women oppress women we
don't oppress women if we hate women why
we get married to four women I never see
someone hate chocolate they have four
bar chocolate that doesn't make any
sense to me we love our woman in Islam
mother have more right than a father in
Islam prophet Muhammad before he passed
away he said take care of women you
understand so alhamdulillah before
prophet Muhammad came a woman used to be
girls used to be buried in the in the
graves alive they never used to inherit
inherit inheritance. They never used to
be able to own business. Came, Islam
came before Britain, before this
revolution in France, women were allowed
to have their own business. My people
did that as well. And my my people wait
revolution in France. No burying burying
women. Yeah. Yeah. The Arabs are doing
that. Yeah. We free from them. Free from
them. You know me. It's not about
nationalism. I will love my English
Muslim brother cuz Islam is more
stronger bonds than my family. You
understand? Because when we die, God is
not going to ask me what tribe you you
from. It's about believe.
Do you love the Christian the same way?
The believers are brothers. I love good
for Christians. No. Do you love the
Christian brother the same way? No, I'm
not gay. I don't love Christian
members cuz I can marry them. This is
important, you know. This is important,
you know. No, no. I love good for you. I
love good for all of you. I'm just I
love good for you. But I told you I
believe you're doing oppression against
God.
I believe you do oppression because why
what is oppression? When you take
something from someone that he deserves
and you give it to the wrong person. So
you by worshiping Jesus, you are taking
God's right, his exclusive rights and
you giving it and I hate that
oppression. So how can I love you when
you have the oppression which is the
evil oppression. That doesn't mean I
take care of you, look after you. If
someone oppress you or stand with you, I
defend you. No, I'm still doing it. You
you know that I've been listening. I've
been Yeah. Yeah. Thank you very much.
the first African patient man. We
Africans, we're not patient. No, no, I'm
not patient. So, what happened? I
allowed you today. I just allowed you.
Go ahead, brother. Go ahead. So, you you
said um you're talking about Christ, our
beloved one, we love you and we are
taking advantage. So, that's the point
that I made that we are taking
advantage. How?
So, what point were you making just a
minute ago? No, he said exclusivity of
worship which you have given to Christ.
No, no. He said Jesus dying and we are
taking advantage of it. He said we are
taking we are taking what he said.
So you don't know what what he said. No
he said about the free pass. Oh you free
pass. Okay. Yes. I believe I said to you
firstly you have to understand the main
points here. You are following Paul. I'm
following Jesus. Uhuh. That's why don't
go back there because it's my strong
point. I know it. No, no, no. The thing
is because you you're going in a
different direction. No, we are saying I
asked you to repeat what you just said
just before I interject you inter
interjected. I said no taking advantage.
No, I didn't say that. Before I before
you interrupted, I said that you are
committing oppression. That's the one.
The oppression you're committing. Who
are we oppressing? You are oppressing
God's rights. God's right. No, let me
finish. Let me finish. God's right that
he should be woripped alone without any
partners. You taking his right to be
woripped alone the almighty and
worshiping a man either Muhammad or
Jesus or tree that is oppression against
God's right which is the most evil thing
human being can commit to oppress God.
God's right not God himself God's right.
God's right to do what? God's right for
us, his right over us, he deserves from
us to worship him alone. Yes. So if us
we start worshiping God tree and a man
beside God, we are not giving God's
right the way he should have it. So what
we doing? We are falling into
oppression. Cuz the meaning of
oppression when you put something or you
give someone something that he does not
deserve. This called oppression. So or
you take something from someone is the
one that doesn't deserve the worship. Is
that what you're trying to say? 100%
Akad Muhammad doesn't deserve it. Okay.
This is why Muslim consistent. No
problem. We are consistent. So this is
why
this is this is why we do things the way
that we do which is worshiping Christ.
We believe that God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believe in that son will not
perish but have eternal life which is
what we have already covered. So that's
the reason we do it not because we want
to to
oppress. We are not trying to oppress
Christ. So according to Jesus Jesus he
did you hear what I said? Yeah. Of
course you pass in the God showing love.
It addresses two points. this point that
I just made here. I was addressing your
point. I answered and you also it's a
wrong answer is one. It might be a wrong
answer. I'll tell you why. From the
Bible, I'll tell you why. No, no, don't
worry. From the Bible. Then also there's
another point that you made earlier that
people say your god or Islam is violent
and all that and it can't be from the a
good god. 20%. Islam is violent
and it doesn't come from a good god.
Islam is who said that? You said people
say that about your religion. No, I said
you have to listen carefully what I
said. What I said people say Islam
oppress women. No, no, no. That just
recent over there. Over there. Yeah.
Yeah. Some people claim maybe you have
to have good memory as well. I have good
memory. Alhamdulillah. I have good
memory. Alhamdulillah. Generally speak
of course. I was
having I will be there. Alhamdulillah.
No Islam. I'm here before before I start
practicing. I'll be over there with
them. Okay. So the other point that I
was at this point that I just made it
also addresses that point for Christians
to say that my God
when he killed Jesus when he sent Christ
to die on the cross it wasn't because he
was cruel. He was showing his love. So
that's why so so God so God committing
murder killing I mean God committed God
committing suicide killing himself is is
love. You're calling it murder. calling
it suicide. Yeah, you're calling it
murder and suicide. No, no murder remove
the feather. No, it's not. It's not.
It's not. I tell you why. No, it's not.
I tell you why. I tell you why. Before,
let me just the first point. Would that
Jesus did he worship himself or he
worshiped God? We're talking about
crucifixion. We're going to move to you
because remember you have so we don't
jump. Yeah. No, we're not jumping with
you point by point. The first point you
mention, you see your memor is weaker
than mine then cuz you forgot it quick.
You first point you mention and you call
the passage in the Bible.
Remember I remember you remember? Yes.
The passage the passage in the Bible
there's no school here. We're not
testing. You see now but the fact that
when I try to you mentioned the first
point you mentioned you said deal with
other points but I'm just reminding you
we have to deal with points after
points. The first point that my that you
said about Jesus God said he loved the
world so much he sent that he sent his
son his begotten son or his son. Yes.
Okay. I don't want to go to the un
authenticity of this passage and so on.
But what I would say to you that does
not disprove my point of you committing
oppression against God's right because
Jesus himself did he pray to himself or
he pray to the father? Who did he
worship? According to the Bible, who did
he worship? According to the Bible,
Jesus worshiped himself or he worshiped
the father. What do you think? It's your
point. No, no. I'm asking you to show
you the point that you mentioned to
rebuke my point is sorry I'm showing you
the point that you mentioned to rebuke
my point is invalid is against you the
fact that you mentioned that I told you
about you oppressing God's right by
giving it to someone else then you went
on to the me the passage in the new
testament that the god loved the world
so much he sent his only begotten son is
invalid so Jesus in the bible worshiped
god
Muslim worship God. Christian worship
Jesus. So who is following Jesus? We are
following Jesus. Jesus worship God. We
believe is God. Okay. Jesus worship God.
You worship Jesus. Are you following
Jesus when you worship God or you not
following Jesus? We follow God the
father, God the son, and God the holy
spirit. Okay. God the godhead. Remember
I mentioned the trinity to accommodate
this? No problem. Did any god from the
godhead that you call worship Jesus? Did
the father
pray to Jesus. Did the Holy Spirit pray
to Jesus? He prayed to God the father.
That's what I'm saying. So you're
proving my point that Jesus was what?
Servant of Allah. And it's exactly what
Allah mentioned in the Quran. Because
remember the reason we say Allah Jesus
never spoke English. Jesus was not from
elephant castle. He was not from
Britain. He was from Palestine. May
Allah free
Palestine. So here Jesus during the time
of Jesus was it was Palestine.
Philistine. He was now in Philistine.
Yes, it's in the Bible. Philistines.
I like that. I'm not I'm not I'm not
going to get into that. You can check
because I know you're wrong. So, I can
get the pass. You get anyway. The point
here is that Jesus Jesus entered
Palestine. That's what we want to see. I
want to mention that's why we always
hear Jesus entering Palestine or leaving
Palestine. No, I didn't tell you Jesus
said I'm entering Palestine. Leaving
Palestine. The word Philistine has been
there for a long time. Anyway, let me
finish point you know that's why I
always say I always say Shia like
Christians you know Shia you know we
have Sunni and Shia Islam
make your point they pray to Hussein
sometimes to Ali and Ali and Hussein
pray to Allah and we Sunnis we pray to
Allah you Christian pray to Jesus Jesus
pray to Allah we pray to Allah so
alhamdulillah we are the true followers
of Jesus and true followers al
pay attention brother So we don't bombs
exploding behind us in case you could be
a Christian man doing it try to kill
some Muslims we are here I'm not saying
it's Muslim I'm not saying no I'm not
saying I'm not saying you say it's
Muslim but I say you Muslims of course
you look speaking together and you can
see your strong man no it's not about
strength it's not about strength chef of
the heart
I I'll tell you I'll tell you why I'm
not scared of you have weapons later on
what you have what do you have inside
look what we say to Look, when you go
home, a famous neighbor. Okay. Oh, yeah.
Mashallah. When you go home and I go
home, let's pray to the God of Abraham.
The God of Jesus and Esau and Jacob. And
the God of Jesus, Yahweh. Yeah. Yeah.
Listen, listen carefully. Let me finish.
Finish. Pray to the God of Abraham. The
God of Esau and Jacob. The God of Jacob.
Let me mention the main one. The God of
Moses and the God of Jesus and the God
of Muhammad. Okay.
You going to do that? I'm not sure about
the God of Muhammad because I put
Muhammad. Okay. Muhammad, the God of
Jesus.
Pray the God of Jesus. I pray to Jesus
because I believe he's God. But Jesus
prayed to another God. How is God? Part
of the Godhead. Father, Son, and the
Holy M. I cannot explain outside of
that. When you say God, I'm thinking the
Godhead. So I believe show you believe
three
gods. Shall I show you? Is the father
fully God?
Yes. God. So when we say fully God mean
the creation is not in need of anyone
else because the father is fully God.
Yes. But we are in need of someone else.
Continue. Now before I continue when you
say the father is a fully god it means
everything that exist is God the father.
Yeah. Listen carefully. The son and the
holy spirit. Listen carefully. Is the
father fully god? Which means everything
that exists relies on him and he's
sufficient for us.
Yes or yes? So we don't need another
god. Take care. Jesus and the holy
spirit is waste of time.
Because if the father we don't need
another one.
So why we have the other two gods in
charge of creating the gods? They were
there from the beginning. Yes. Creating
ghosts. Who creating gods is
paganism. We are saying we don't need
her.
Islam I showed you earlier I am
listening but I'm just showing you
earlier on how I show you Islam is so
clear you know the beauty of Islam Allah
is not the god of the the philosophers
only Allah is the god of everyone the
Islamic message the person that works in
bush market and the person that teaches
in Oxford University they can understand
the Islamic message as for Christianity
literally you have to study philosophy
to try to understand the the the the
core teaching of Christianity. Why are
they Islamic philosophers then? It's for
not a good point. I was asking question.
Oh yeah, it's not because from the day
one from the day one
our philosophers yes Islamist
philosophers these philosophers they
were heavily influenced by the Greek
philosophy like the Christian
philosophers. Philosophy if you mean to
utilize your sound intellect the way
Allah created it. Everyone's
philosopher. If you mean that which
doesn't mean that philosophy which
heavily influenced by that you start
having that two types there's two types
of skepticism there's a praiseworthy
blame worthy one praiseworthy sometimes
you doubt some things the philosophy the
blame worthy one are taught to play to
you start doubting everything everything
you start doubting even some of their
own existence so Islamic philosophers
will not accept it that's
what many scholars has nothing to do I'm
married brother if she's the last woman
on I would never marry her Islam. If I
marry her, I will commit suicide. Anyway
of
Islam is haram and Islam.
Jesus Christ is not a Muslim.